la deuxième idée qu'il faut avoir en
tête et qui est une idée importante et
qui n'est pas forcément une idée
réjouissante
c'est que nous allons devoir apprendre à
vivre avec le virus
non pas que nous l'acceptions non pas
que nous ayons baisser les bras face à
l'épidémie au contraire mais parce que
nous constatons que la population n'est
pas immunisée
le sera t elle un jour cela dépendra de
ce qu'a dit madame le professeur de ce
que la science sera déterminé c'est à
dire des caractéristiques de la maladie
mais quoi qu'il en soit aujourd'hui la
population n'est pas immunisée
la circulation du virus a été
suffisamment restreinte pour qu' un
nombre trop limité de personnes étaient
en contact avec le virus et donc la
population n'est pas immunisée on
considère que les modèles qui sont en
train d'être travaillée et va lui être
deux à 6 millions le nombre de nos
concitoyens qui sont entrés en contact
avec le virus
on est très loin de ce qu'on appelle
parfois l'immunité de de masse ou
l'immunité populationnelle la population
n'est pas immunisée
nous n'aurons pas de vaccin rapidement
en tout cas rien à un horizon
raisonnable avant 2021 est peut-être un
peu plus loin il n'y a pas à ce stade de
traitements efficaces démontrer ou
connue même si la recherche est
évidemment intense et même si les
scientifiques les médecins sont
déterminés et optimistes sur leur
capacité à trouver un traitement
aujourd'hui et dans un avenir proche en
tout cas il n'y a pas encore de
traitement connu cela nous laisse un
instrument la prévention qui va être
déterminante dans la façon dont nous
allons procéder aux déconfinement dans
la façon dont nous allons vie
après le confinement vivre avec le virus
cette prévention cette façon de lutter
contre la circulation du virus va
reposer sur trois éléments essentiels et
c'est ce que je veux indiquer avant de
passer la parole au ministre de la santé
d'abord les gestes barrière vous les
connaissez ils sont absolument
essentielles et ne pas les respecter
les prendre avec un peu plus de facilité
un peu plus de décontraction
parce que ça fait longtemps parce qu'on
a entendu quelques bonnes nouvelles
c'est littéralement nous exposer à une
reprise de l'épidémie à une reprise de
la circulation et de l'accélération de
la circulation du virus
nous allons donc devoir vivre avec le
respect de gestes barrières de mesures
barrières sur lesquels le ministre va
revenir c'est le premier aspect
indispensable le deuxième aspect ce sont
les tests et singulièrement les tests
virologiques le ministre y reviendra
pour pouvoir vivre avec le virus pour
pouvoir recommencer à vivre normalement
si j'ose dire avec ce virus qui
circulent nous allons devoir tester et
testé vite et massivement tous ceux qui
sont susceptibles de le porter tous ceux
qui présentent des symptômes ou qui ont
été en contact avéré avec présenteraient
des symptômes et qui ont été contact
avéré avec un malade
nous allons devoir tester beaucoup vite
rapidement et le troisième élément qui
accompagne cette politique celle
isolement des porteurs du virus
si nous ne mettons pas en oeuvre ces
trois axes alors nous avons une
politique incomplète les seuls gestes
barrières ne suffisent pas et nous
connaissons des pays pourtant très bien
organisés dans lesquelles les gestes
barrières sont observés avec une rigueur
et un civisme qui font parfois envie et
qui pourtant
alors même qu'ils portent des masques
alors même qu'ils respectent les gestes
barrière voix l'épidémie se développer
et s'accélérer sur leur territoire ce
qui les conduit pour certains d'entre
eux a procédé au confinement les gestes
barrières les tests rapides et
l'isolément de ceux qui sont regardés
comme porteurs du virus
c'est sur ces trois éléments que nous
allons organiser notamment le plan de
déconfinement que je présenterai dans
deux semaines